[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan on sensor prime
time for liz truss britain's broken
brits are broke so what is her plan to
rescue us can we trust in trust
tonight's panel will debate a historic
day in british politics
and of course at the top of the pm's
intray the cost of living
plus just when we thought he couldn't
get any worse for britain
princess pinocchio jets in to lecture us
all about equality and poverty
[Music]
live from london this is piers morgan
uncensored
well good evening good to be back
welcome to piers morgan uncensored and
welcome to britain's new prime minister
liz truss i would say congratulations to
mistrust but there's no time for any
celebration this country is in a state
of absolute shambles
inflation is raging energy and food
prices are rocketing thousands if not
tens of thousands of small businesses
face complete ruin millions of families
are waking up wondering how they pay
their bills people are getting poorer
every day they're feeling desperate and
they're feeling they're safe violent
crime is soaring with shocking
consequences nine-year-old olivia pratt
corbil shot dead in her own home
pensioner thomas o'halloran who raised
money for charity by busking on the
street killed on his mobility scooter
young kids stabbing each other with
impunity sometimes to death with
machetes
the nhs is in intensive care creaking at
the scene from a pandemic this caused
chronic staff shortages a massive
waiting list union strikes and picket
lines are bringing chaos to our daily
lives illegal migration across the
channel is getting immeasurably worse
not better the ill-conceived rwanda
policy is in tatters
housing is in crisis with rental costs
out of control the pound has crashed to
a 37-year low against the dollar and of
course the ukraine war continues to
cause immeasurable harm to european
economies and security but if ever there
was one symbol of where britain's been
heading it's sort of a torrents of raw
sewage flowing into our seas and onto
our coastlines
forgive my language prime minister but
britain is quite literally turning
so my question is this
what are you going to do about it
a clean break with boris johnson's
disastrous three years of disorder and
deceit would be a good place to start
boris you got brexit done
you crushed jeremy corbyn
you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to vladimir putin
you were admired from kiev to carlisle
did you know that that long prolonged
very awkward silence
never mind from keeve to carlisle boris
johnson isn't even admired by people in
a room full of conservatives
and he didn't get brexit done really did
he he wrapped a bandage around the
northern ireland problem left the wound
untreated
and where exactly are all those promised
benefits of brexit right now the
negatives are a lot more painfully
obvious
boris johnson promised a hell of a lot
and he delivered very little
this trust his campaign has also
promised a hell of a lot including tax
cuts at a time when most economists
think they would be inflation-fuelling
madness
well prime minister now is the time to
get real
britain doesn't need to be told we can
have our cake and eat it anymore there's
no cake left
boris johnson's britain was defined by
complacency chaos and calamity prime
minister trust your brit must be about
solutions integrity hope and honesty
tell us the truth about the mess we're
in tell us the truth about the pain that
lies ahead tell us the truth about what
you're going to do about it that will
actually work
your in trade today must look like the
leaning tower of pisa
your country is on its knees the office
you now hold has been disgraced your
people are angry they're scared and they
need answers right now
you liz trust wanted this job
you spent weeks promising us that you
can fix it you have the solutions well
britain needs you to keep that promise
and keep it fast and will be very
unforgiving if you fail us
well let's go now to talk to these
political owners kate mccann uh kate
well good to see you again how are you
you miss me
i'm good of course we missed you pierce
it's all we thought about all summer was
where you were i don't think i've ever
ever seen a less sincere response on
national television to a question and
for the record contrary to the popular
myth that i was gallivanting around for
weeks on end summing myself i spent half
of it in maximum security prisons in
america interviewing serial killers
which i have to say on balance was a bit
like covering this conservative party
leadership race in terms of pain
[Laughter]
i was going to ask you what you'd done
to deserve that not quite well look we
got a new prime minister no big surprise
liz trust one probably the gap a bit
narrower than people were expecting uh
but the general belief was she had it in
the bag from pretty early on because the
conservative party membership 170 odd
thousand of them who voted in the end uh
would tend to be i guess more drawn to a
character like liz trust sort of maggie
light figure if you if you want a a
phrase for her uh the question for her
is how is she going to deal kate with
what is i would imagine in terms of
political uh
analysis going back 100 years one of the
most difficult hospital passes any prime
minister has come in
holding voluntarily because she ran for
this that i can never remember this is a
very difficult time to run this country
it's near impossible to be honest and i
think the thing that liz trust is going
to find out very quickly when she walks
into number 10 officially tomorrow when
she is the prime minister is that she is
not going to be able to keep everybody
happy and of course that's the one thing
that you don't want to have to admit at
any time when you're in number 10 but
especially in your first week because
her party are looking to her to reunite
them they want to see her put people in
the cabinet that are not just those who
factor through this contest her urge is
probably going to be not to do that
though because she knows the scale of
the task ahead and if you think about it
you know today behind the scenes those
who work with liz trust are briefing
that the scale of the numbers here
involved potentially a hundred billion
pounds worth of support and really big
questions which remain unanswered
tonight where's that money coming from
who's paying for it are the energy
companies going to foot some of the bill
are we all going to be paying for it for
the next 10 years every single answer to
that question is unsavory for somebody
and liz trust is going to have to find
it and deliver that answer as quickly as
maybe even thursday and it won't just be
everyone in the country who wants to
understand it it will be her party too
and there were rumblings today i was
saying earlier on
at that qe2 center when she was
delivering her speech you know mps
watching and waiting and suggesting that
their patients would run out fairly
quickly if they didn't see that she was
going to bring everyone along with her
and the early signs are suggestions from
number 10 tonight that there could be a
complete clear out of everybody who's
gone before even those who some say she
should keep because they will be helpful
over what will be a really difficult
period i mean to me the fundamental uh
problem she's going to have is keeping
the commitment she's made
to cut taxation for people at a time
when most economists i've read and heard
from in the last few weeks say that
would be complete madness that there is
simply not the money there to cut taxes
and to do all the borrowing that she
needs to do to help people how she going
to do this
well remember it's not just that she
said she would cut taxes it's that she
has berated politicians who give with
one hand and take away with the other
hoping that the public don't notice and
ultimately what's going to be really
difficult for her here is when she does
look at the books and she sees the scale
of the problem with energy bills as i
said before there has to be an answer to
it and ultimately even if you say well
it will be government borrowing that
will come back on taxpayers and that is
all of us even if it's not instant there
will be a long tail to this which no
prime minister really wants to sign up
for and remember she's also talking
about longevity in energy markets and
making big changes that will prepare us
for the future again significant
investment more money and as you say at
a time when she's promised that she will
be cutting taxes and giving families
more back in their pockets i think that
is worrying the trust team it's worrying
mps too
but just the scale as you said i mean
it's unprecedented for a prime minister
have to have to walk into something like
this and that's before we mention the
problems you know northern ireland
brexit inflation other really big issues
which will be on her doorstep two yeah
and you know i i
would have preferred to see rishi sunak
to be honest to be prime minister simply
because of his experience during the
pandemic i thought he was great with the
furloughs game and so on uh but it was
an interesting handover wasn't it when
she was announced as a winner normally
you would have expected her to at least
shake the hand of the person she just
beat totally ignored it bang just no
you're done mate um which it says to me
she's got no intention of putting her in
his cabinet even if he would like to and
what worries me okay about this cabinet
is a bunch of rookies in many cases uh
completely untested
in this kind of uh situation we're in
which is unprecedented uh how are they
gonna fare these people you know when i
see some of the names running great
offices of state like well have you have
you run a welt stool before i mean
seriously
we are in an absolute crisis
are these people good enough
well that's the question that she's
going to have to answer and she started
doing it you know she started to move
out some of those big names pretty
battelle for example and more to come
those people that will not feature among
her top team but i think in those big
offices quasi quattang for example
potentially the chancellor we suspect
he's written an article today aimed at
trying to calm the nerves of the country
yes but largely the financial markets i
think there is a sense that people like
him do get it and that there is some
real grip and grit within that top team
of people but the bigger question will
be is there a place for rishi sunak is
there a place for some of those wise
heads who have experienced but maybe
didn't back this trust during this
contest and will she be a big enough
person to put them among her top table
because you know she hasn't as you said
at the very start of this chat she
didn't win over you know all mps in
parliament no she didn't do as well as
previous leaders in this contest 57
boris johnson 66
david cameron 67
you know the polling suggests that among
2019 conservative voters trust in her
and faith in her sticking to her word
has gone down
throughout this contest she comes into
office not riding high not with chat
around an early election and a honeymoon
period but into headlong huge problems
and disunity already and that's really
difficult and remember we've replaced
the prime minister a number of times and
once mps get used to that cycle of chaos
they don't feel so bad about doing it
again
right they've got a bloodlust i can hear
anne whitaking to my right here
growling in i think discontent to some
of the things you were saying kate
mccann which is always a good sign would
like a bit of growling on the show okay
good to see you again i'm sure we'll be
back tomorrow thank you very much for
now though uh well like i said this
trust prepares to meet the queen
tomorrow and name her new government
we've got a whole
pack here
jumping at the bit aren't you pack if
you say so
it's a great fact can we get stuck into
all this why is this disgraced leader of
the last government already plotting his
return that's one question should boris
button it and talking of buttoning it
meghan markle is preaching about
equality right now in manchester and i
would love to show you what she's saying
but i couldn't give a
let's go to the break
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to pierce morgan uncensored
uh princess pinocchio is still jabbering
away up in manchester but we have zero
interest in anything she has to say
uh the conservative party that has a
final uh got a new leader and we have a
new prime minister across the country
and yet before liz trusts
even meets the queen tomorrow she is
facing talk of a plot to ouster and a
campaign to bring back boris johnson god
forbid with rumors of a new book and
newspaper column plus giddy talks of
political comeback will boris be a thorn
in liz trust's site is it time for him
to just shove off and button it we're
joining me now political journalist
averson teen economist emily sheffield
and former conservative minister and
whitaker welcome to all of you my first
peers pack of the new season and you
were literally growling at some of the
things you
haven't been there five minutes right
and there's already this unity and
everybody's talking about who's going to
be chancellor vicks jacob who's going to
be home secretary actually if she wants
to win the next general election the
most significant appointment from the
point of view not of the country but of
the party in parliament will be the
chief whip because
the the party in parliament it's
panic-prone it's chaotic uh it believes
that whatever the opinion polls are
doing today they will certainly be doing
in two years time it has no long-term
perspective and the mere fact that
within two minutes of a prime minister
being chosen they can be talking about
you know plots and ousting i mean says
it all the problems
is the clock is ticking to the next
election and so with every day week
month that goes by nearer to that
election
mps as we know get very self-serving
very anxious about their own job post
that election and if they think things
are really floundering william hague's
written a column uh for the times which
is in tomorrow's paper liz trust is the
pm who will either take us through the
gathering storm of domestic and global
crises or we are lost she's the captain
under which the good ship britain will
find a safe harbor or sink i mean my god
this is like i don't think i've ever
read that on day one of someone becoming
prime minister but therefore gives the
captain a chance rather than what is she
selling yourself
rather than me
you hang on
a chance look hang on you've been
allowed to finish
my show
what have she done for your show but
you've invited me on what is the captain
you wanted
what i'm going to say is give the
captain a chance because if you start
with a mutiny the ship ain't going
anywhere what if the captain is steering
us straight into the titanic we cannot
know that we know she wants to cut taxes
we also know many economists think
that's complete madness but we also know
that some economists do not if you don't
actually give her a chance then for a
certainty the whole margaret thatcher
when she came in big myth that she
actually cut taxes she raised taxes to
start with until she got the economy
back on track then she cut them why
isn't trust doing that
truss has made a very clear point that
what she wants to know she hasn't may i
finish as what she wants to do
is to stimulate growth now give her the
chance if it fails piers you'll be the
first to show the fails we're all in the
car
i think this mutiny is being rather
overplayed you've had steve baker today
who is the arch rebel has already come
out saying i'm not going to rebel i've
been doing it for years i'm exhausted i
mean he's not exhausted at all
and i think a lot of the party actually
know it is absolute suicide for the
tories if they mutiny against her it
doesn't mean they're not going to be
silent i agree with you anne but i don't
think you're going to see the kind of
mutiny that you've seen with boris
johnson what you had with boris johnson
is a a leader who didn't know how to
lead let's face it he did over some
issues i do think he's definitely
ukraine was correct and vaccines and
vaccines but
i don't think we're in the same period
now brexit is done
and we've got an economic crisis and
everyone's saying oh lizzy's got this
terrible entry well she does but she's
also got a single issue she's got to
really solve in the next two years which
is the economy so she can unite her
party behind that if she wants to win
the next election the one thing she's
absolutely got to get right because no
one believes she can fix the nhs in the
next few years is green shooters that's
all she needs to prove by that here's
the problem i think it doesn't matter
who's in charge of the country right now
this is a
basket case situation where almost every
metric you look at for britain right now
is a disaster i mean there's not a way
of looking at it look at what's
happening with the pound against a
dollar
when i was thinking america's got talent
as a judge in 2006
the dollar rate from memory was
something like 210 right for every pound
you got two dollars and 10 cents it's
now 114
think about that difference i mean i
think about it often i think that some
people on this panel don't think about
that because there have been a few
events over the last 12 years that have
led to that directly namely brexit and
namely 12 years of the tories being in
power and not knowing how to govern the
country properly evidently but look i
think you know liz trust today should
have got up on that podium and finally
revealed what she's going to do for the
millions of people right now who are
looking at the next couple of months and
genuinely don't know how they're going
to pay their bills i think it's so
absurd that we're talking about tax cuts
or give the woman a chance like i don't
care i want money i want to know how how
on earth people are going to pay for
things i just think it's just it just
feels a bit too long i think wait it's a
bit uh you can't she can't say that
literally as she accepts the crown
because she's not prime minister yet so
she is no but she can't actually because
she's not prime minister yet she has to
meet the queen
so she can she's been part of the
government for the last 10 years
tomorrow i mean my problem
is this trust has been there for 10
years she singularly seems to have
failed upwards no one says she was a
great success all the trade deals
i don't think you can point to this
trust being a massive success in any of
the jobs she's i'm
sorry a massive baby
i don't see i don't see a run of great
successes we go well that person should
be prime minister i see somebody sort of
toddled along in underperforming
governments
ending in this car crash with boris
johnson to which she was very aligned to
him and remains very aligned to him
whether it's brexit to
ukraine
for loyalty well no something well it's
interesting to me
didn't win this because he was seen to
be the guy who pulled the knife into
boxing
but he was right to wield the knife
boris johnson is right to have gone
richie's soon that was correct now we've
lost probably the
biggest intellect in that cabinet has
now been frozen out and gone and we have
this untrusted trust that we have to all
trust
and i'm just not sure i do trust her no
we don't i'm sure you're i'm sure you
didn't
but fundamentally because we don't i
keep being told she's the next maggie
thatcher maggie thatcher would not be
cutting taxes right now if liz trust
tries to cut taxation right now i think
it will be an apocalyptic move by a new
prime minister because it's only just
coming in
to be clear the 1979 manifesto maybe too
young way too young but the 1979
manifesto when thatcher came in did not
mention half the things that she
subsequently did it was very very broad
brush do you think this trust has it in
her to surprise us and to be bold and
dynamic i think she might i'm not going
to say she will i don't have a crystal
ball and only what do we know about i
mean i don't know i don't know anything
after six weeks really i once asked her
on good morning britain i think what
seven times eight was or something and
she spent about five seconds agonizing
it was something
it's because she has one and she played
those members like a like a you know
stroking a purring cat don't you think
statements i think what we might see and
the tory party might then rebel in a
year the right is she's promised this
very new radical right agenda
but is she actually going to deliver it
because we don't have her vision yet
every single thing she has said she is
actually already utilized so what's the
deal with the women we don't know
anything about the world really i
watched her on laura koonsburg's new
uh show on bbc on sunday and she talks
in this strange robotic
very precise
until she has a voice
until she trained her voice
her mind is computing what to say yeah
or what not to do i don't mind somebody
thinking let's take a listen to
people know what i'm talking about
boris you got brexit done
you crushed jeremy corbyn
you rolled out the vaccine
and you stood up to vladimir putin
you were admired from kiev to carlisle
three of those i i can sign up to i
actually voted for boris johnson
precisely to stop jeremy corbyn becoming
prime minister he would have been even
worse so tick on that tick on ukraine
you know i there's a lot of things the
vaccine rolled out he made a big call
with kate bingham which was proven to be
entirely correct there are things that
you can take in boris's box big things
yeah but the damage that was done from
the constant lying the constant
dissembling the constant breach of trust
for the british public culminating in
partygate with half a down history on
the lash every night as we're all kept
from seeing dying loved ones and that's
what you want to hear liz trust saying
today well no what i wanted this shot to
do today was was somehow she did the
right thing she praised her predecessor
which is the normal guy why would you
play something literally over 50
ministers voted to get rid of because
she actually set out what she was
praising him for and you yourself have
agreed i think she did that and you
yourself have agreed she only won this
race by sucking up to borrow back to
your point about her performance though
because i think we've got to talk about
labour a bit more
that is who she's got to beat at the
next direction and he also is not a
brilliant performer he doesn't have a
huge amount of christmas it's going to
be quite all right well let me bring a
neighbor on labour leaders who are not
right
charismatic
is quite robotic as well as a public
speaker there's no question he's not mr
charismatic i don't think he needs to be
if i'm kirsten right now i'm thinking
you know what the best strategy is sit
back and let them drive this into the
titanic yeah but we've had that strategy
for a good two years from labour and
it's the reason that they're not 20
points ahead in the polls i mean right
now if sake in my opinion had any sense
he'd be out there calling for uh for
another general election that's what
he'd be doing but look you know you
watch that speech with liz trust she's
extremely robotic she's extremely boring
i don't think she won over the the
conservative electorate i think those
conservatives as that senior tory mp
told us halfway through this campaign
they would never elect a person of color
and that's what the issue was she won by
default i'm sorry i i really wouldn't
yeah no i'm not sure i agree with you i
really do not
although i'm not a conservative or i'm
not in the conservative party anymore
i'm very proud of the fact that in that
election the final two were a woman and
somebody of ethnic origin and the
trouble with labour is talks big about
those things delivers nothing i mean
that is true
the labour party has never had i agree
with that any leader who's not a white
bloke yeah correct i mean that's just a
fact they bang on they virtual signal
away about diversity there's absolutely
nothing diverse about labour leadership
ever but i think it's going to be very
interesting on wednesday at pmq's
because
he should really kierstarma tear into
her he has got so as you as you're
opening to this program broken britain
nhs on its knees social care on its
knees six police forces on special
measures including the met the spate of
murders he has got so much uh ammunition
honestly some young kids but if he
doesn't win the next election she
doesn't deserve somebody was shot i got
back to britain uh on uh two nights ago
and somebody was shot around the corner
in kensington right which is i think the
wealthiest borough in london that we
fought the country and someone was shot
dead in the street near a restaurant
that i go into quite a lot and i was
quite i shouldn't have been shot because
there's violent crime everywhere but he
brought it home to me
britain is getting very violent we are
getting people shot quite regularly the
police are ineffective
well they're on enough of them because
because the tories took 20 000 cops off
the streets
that's why there aren't enough of them
that is quite true but also they're
focused on the wrong place how did the
party's supposed to be so they're
focused on the wrong price
party based around law and order take
twenty thousand police off the streets
well at the valley madness the fact is
that we have been well we they have
well you wouldn't have done probably
that's true let's take a short break
when i come back talk more about the
cost of living i want to talk to one of
the biggest supermarket bosses in the
country and to a nurse
who has cancer can't afford to stop
working because of what is going on with
the economy we'll talk to both of them
off the break and get the panel reaction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well welcome back to pearson
organization prime minister must be a
holiday from hell she inherits the worst
cost of living crisis in recent memory
today she promised a bold plan to tackle
rising energy costs and she's reportedly
mulling a package of up to 100 billion
pounds to freeze energy bills there's
all this energy food prices are soaring
too last year loaf of bread was one
pound fifteen today you're paying one
pound twenty four four pints of milk was
one pound sixteen that's now one pound
fifty the average price for a pack of
spaghetti was 52 p that's gone to 84 p
you could pick up a can of premium brand
baked beans for 83 p now you're paying
one pound 20. this story of course can
be told in america and australia around
the world but joining me now is kerry
george a 48 year old woman of two to
continue working as a nurse whilst
receiving treatment for breast cancer to
help keep a roof over her family's head
kerry thank you so much for joining me
i'm so sorry for what you've been going
through
this trust new prime minister she
promised two things today one to fix the
economic problems we have and
specifically to deliver a rescue plan
for the nhs
obviously given your position where
you're continuing to work in the nhs
whilst
actually being a patient yourself you've
got cancer
and really feeling the pinch
economically what do you make of this
and what do you want to say to the prime
minister what should be her priorities
well there should definitely be money
put into the nhs
i mean
quite frankly i think it's ridiculous
that um the nurses have been offered
such a low
pay rate rise
after everything that they've gone
through with their corporate and
everything
something needs to happen straight away
this there is there's no staff
anywhere there's a staff shortage
on all roads wherever i go and that
really needs to be addressed it seems to
me that the pandemic really knocked the
nhs for six in the sense that
a lot of staff had to take time off
because they themselves got the virus
some lost their lives a lot of uh staff
went back to their original countries
you know brexit i don't think has helped
at all in this process
and you're left with a streamlined very
short-staffed system trying to cope now
with a massive backlog of cases of
non-covet cases we know this waiting
list through the roof so the nhs wants
this great beacon of how you should do
health care in a country now looks like
it's creaking at the seams
yeah that i mean and the intake of
nurses of student nurses is shot down as
well it doesn't seem to be that
incentive to want to go into the
profession
because it's
the way
nurses have been treated so badly and
and doctors do
what is morale like amongst amongst
medical staff now in hospitals
it it's very low at the moment and um
it's a very high stress level on the
staff who are there all the time it um
the burden of work on them and ratio
between staff and patients it's just way
too demanding at the moment
and you know
staff are begin gonna come stressed and
that's gonna lead to more sickness in
turn
and um even less shocked even more
shortage and how are you doing kerry
you're having to have chemo and continue
working because you can't afford to to
not work right
i am i'm exhausted um
my plan was to work
through the chemo
up until i became
i'm too well to work
but um i've been told by my doctor today
that
it's not a good idea of me going to work
at the moment
so unfortunately i think i'm going to
have to
start thinking about my health at this
point and then what will you do what
will you do about money if you are
forced to do that
well
this is the problem this is the reason i
wanted to work as long as uh i can
because um
well i put him for a personal
independence payment which has recently
been declined
on the grounds that i haven't been there
long enough
um
how they came to that decision i i will
never know when for anyone with a
disability whether it happens overnight
i mean
you you need something in place now
not in six months time down the down
down the road you you just haven't got
that money in the bank to see through
so
um
it's pretty diarrhea a friend a good
friend in work
um lauren has set up a gofundme page
and i've had donations from the nursing
staff on church which i'm just so
grateful for everyone's been so lovely i
don't know what i would have done well
kerry
uh look i wish you all i wish you all
the very best with your treatment and
it's obviously not going to be easy for
you
like so many people when you have to go
home and you can't work and you're
worried about the bills and energy costs
are flying up food
are flying up i'm about to interview the
boss of iceland supermarket do you shop
there
yes i do yes
how have you found the costs of of food
in iceland products
i think well i think iceland is
generally pretty good
um
i mean food has gone up everywhere it's
at the moment it's it's the same
everywhere but um i have started using
iceland
a bit more than i used to
because you can't you can't pick a
bargain says
well he'll be pleased to hear that uh
kerry i've got to leave it there thank
you very much keep battling we're all
behind you and i wish you all the very
best
thank you so much all right all the best
well let's talk now let's talk about
dimension director of iceland uh
is that kerry uh despite all she's going
through she's converted to iceland and
i've come to to some point about iceland
in a minute but
just you know you've been running a big
supermarket chain for a while now
have you ever faced anything quite like
this even at the start of the pandemic
is this as bad as you've ever known
things
yeah hi good evening pierce and i i
think that's fair to say um i've
certainly never known anything like this
and actually the business was set up 52
years ago by my mum and dad and uh dad
told me the other day he's never known
anything like this either bearing in
mind iceland was started in 1970 the
all-price shock decade when inflation
was running in mid 20 so really quite
sobering and i suppose the difference
now is that it's coming at us from all
angles you know we have some labor
shortages um we have a high oil price
and we we have brexit and some tariffs
to deal with but then of course um we
also have uh the the energy price which
is not just affecting our consumers and
our suppliers but also uh running shops
like this as well right i mean for for a
company like iceland i mean do you know
what you pay per year for energy just
for to keep the stores going in a
regular year and you know what it's
likely to go up to with this surge
i do uh i can't tell you but last year
just for for a guide um we our
electricity bill was 60 million pounds
um and and this year it will be many
times more um and that's the reality
that we're facing but also smes small
businesses on on every high street all
around the uk
so
the level of this uh crisis can't be
overestimated and i think you're right
to compare it to
the start of the pandemic or indeed the
financial crisis um 10 15 years ago what
we have is an energy market that is
completely dislocated it's bearing no
semblance to reality and it's making it
impossible to uh to plan and for us to
to plan ahead to open shops and so that
we can keep on doing good things for our
customers customers like kerry um so
that that we can be there for them
through through this cost of living
crisis i mean despite kerry's support uh
it's been reported that iceland a 6.6
price rise since 2021 the largest of any
uk
supermarket is that right and if so why
yeah i mean we we obviously started a
very low base
and it depends what you measure but it
is true that our prices have gone up um
as have all of our competitors however
we are famous for value as kerry uh said
so um we work day and night to keep our
prices absolutely as low as possible you
mentioned milk uh it's now one pound
fifty in competitors it's slightly less
here we don't make any money out of that
and uh but if it's not if it's all like
right if it's all light for light though
why is yours gone up by a bigger
percentage
um some products will have done but some
products won't you can still find uh the
cheapest uh bread milk um obviously our
frozen range we've also done things like
freezing the price of all of our one
pound lines over 200 lines to the end of
the year we used to make 25 margin
profit out of that now we're going to
lose money so we're having to invest
we're having to change our operating
model
and we're having to step up for our
customers what we need now is the
government to step up as well for uh
small businesses but also for big
businesses like us they need to protect
the whole business ecosystem we have a
lot of small suppliers who rely on us to
do well we have thirty thousand
colleagues five million customers a week
a thousand stores so it's really
important that the government also helps
big business because it's well it is
that is true
it's also important that the bosses and
companies take care of their staff the
sun reported two weeks ago that you pay
your staff the lowest of any major
supermarket nine pounds an hour again is
that right and if so no that's wrong
no that's wrong we we pay them nine
pound fifty as a frontline colleague and
it tapers up from there now a couple of
years ago we were amongst the best
players on the high street and i'm not
proud of the fact now that we're just in
the pack with everyone else but it's a
reality of the uh spiraling operating
costs that that we're facing if i can
pay them more i will
you're paying them under a living wage
right now right we don't mess around
no no
no of course we're not and uh we don't
mess around with zero hours
16 hours and over
uh in in london yeah and and that's what
we pay there but uh as as a frontline
colleague elsewhere nine pound 50.
it's illegal to
it's it's illegal to pay less so we we
certainly don't do that but we um talk
about minimum wage we do everything so
well i'm talking about living wage not
minimum wage
oh okay the real yes exactly the real
real living wage which is something that
we aspire i'm just curious why
i'm just saying that you do apparently
pay your staff less than anybody else
i'm just curious as to why because i
think it's incumbent on the government
to help businesses like you but also
incumbent on bosses and companies like
you and your company to take care of
their staff
oh absolutely and that's why we're
giving them uh 15 discount um for
ongoing now we'll give them bonuses at
christmas um we're trying to do
everything we can and the moment we can
afford to pay more we will bearing in
mind we lost money last year we will do
this year um but you know we want to
create jobs we're one of the few
retailers that's actually growing we
opened 30 shops last year that's 30.
okay if there's one thing you can tell
this so this is about helping the high
streets around the uk all right if
there's one thing you could get liz
trust to do and announce tomorrow to
help business what would it be
energy price cap for business big
business as well as small
don't just focus on further rate relief
for pubs and restaurants all business
needs supporting that's what she can do
tomorrow and then longer term we need to
fix our completely broken energy markets
okay and the they're spiraling out of
control and that's what needs to be done
and it can be done quite quickly as well
all right richard walker thank you i
appreciate you joining me
thank you
just very quick reaction to to both
those interviews there i mean they've
got the sharp end of this porn nurse
got chemo treatment having to work now
i'm going to give that up yeah can i can
i just say to kerry if she's still
listening
focusing for a moment on the refusal of
that payment she should if she hasn't
already done it get in touch with her mp
yesterday and i do mean that because
that's what he he or she is therefore
okay uh that's the first thing uh on the
nhs just let me make this comment covid
isn't the cause of this it was the
catalyst
i said 20 years ago in 1998 you might
just remember it i made a major party
conference speech though i do remember
the nhs would not survive i think the
system is broken
well it was set up for a completely
different set of circumstances
what did you make of richard walker you
know look these bosses are in difficult
positions
um and you know it's going to be very
difficult to see how they get out of
this with the energy bills alone for
supermarket stores no i i absolutely
agree i think it is worth mentioning
that quite a lot of businesses will have
fixed their energy for a while so not
every business is going to need it i
think you do need so we don't have a
massive covered cash handout again
i do think
businesses are going to have to be
stress tested that if your energy bills
are capped you don't need a massive
handout but every business is going to
need to i agree final word ava gonna
leave it there but final word to you
about that no one needs an energy cap we
need a wealth tax that's what we need
okay wealth tax well why not i don't
mind paying more uh thank you both uh to
all my wonderful much appreciated coming
up the deluded duchess is back in town
big yawn preaching away dog knows about
what i don't really care but we're gonna
debate whether she should be here at all
why should she be back here with a
halfway husband after trashing our royal
family we'll debate that after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back i regret to announce
halfway harry and the preaching princess
pinocchio are back in the uk banging on
about the usual stuff whining moaning
preaching about quality poverty usual
thing
my question is what are they doing here
here's a little clip not much because
we're not really that interested but
have a listen to this
it is
very nice to be back in the uk have any
of you today so far had that feeling
that pinch me moment where you just go
how am i here yes how are you here and
why are you here
all you've done is trash this country
trash the royals trash the monarchy and
upset the queen what are you doing here
well lawyer paula rowan adrian and talk
to your contributor esther crack over
here so paula
why why are they here they hate this
country they hate the royal family
they've disowned the royal family they
hate the monarchy and all it stands for
they keep their royal titles and fleece
them for hundreds of millions of dollars
to the highest bidder what are they
doing back here okay so first of all
they were invited secondly i've never
heard them say that they hate this
country i've never heard them say they
hate the royal family and i know that
the facts are very important to you
peers so let's deal with the facts they
are working they are here to blend
they're earning their netflix money
they're being followed by netflix
everywhere they go so they're doing
their charity work they're coming along
patting people on the head so that
netflix can record it for their
lovey-dovey documentary which they're
getting paid by the way yes i'm told
over a hundred million dollars for this
just work doing charity work is
equivalent to you patting somebody else
they don't do any duty they abandon the
country they abandon royal duty but they
want to keep the titles they want to
fleece the titles
i'm just not having this yeah i think
it's complete double standard they are
damaging the monarchy with every
interview they give chip chip chip away
meghan markle we're all a bunch of
racists apparently british journalists
called her child the n-word no evidence
apparently someone in the royal family
expressed concern about archie's skin
color no evidence and so on she sprays
out this stuff damaging the monarchy
damaging the country
no evidence ever gets produced but i
think she's holding the royal family
hostage with that because if you've if
you've been a victim of racist abuse why
don't you name the person because you
know if you don't say who it is you're
tarnishing that the
painting the royal family with that
brush but my question is isn't harry
potter have you ever been a victim of
racism oh i have actually and have you
always named oh absolutely you've always
known because
i've been a victim of racist abuse i
know exactly who the people are who have
racially abused me i know i know where
they're working i know what they're
doing and to date i haven't named them
because i will be told where is my proof
and no doubt there are a number of you
no no no no no no no no
the biggest allegations of bullying
against any member of the royal family
were against meghan markle against two
pas who apparently were bullied so much
they had to leave
tears every single day they went to work
so that you know she denied it
this is what i was being told
what you were told where is the evidence
and this is what you have to be careful
about because we want to have a very
dignified discussion about this we don't
want to do this backwards
he said he said and this is what happens
and that's the only basis that we have
of course they were invited because
charities want publicity my point is
they are bringing a netflix camera crew
this is why william won't see them this
is why charles isn't seen that's why the
queen won't see them they don't trust
them they don't trust them not to put it
all on camera to put it all in harry's
terrible book where he'll cause even
more misery for the royal family and i
think at what point does this stop these
two apparently
these two apparently left the country
because they wanted privacy i can agree
with you on the fear that charles and
william are probably grappling with at
the moment because you're absolutely
right harren and megan will not be
silenced they will not be seen but hold
on they feel that
let me make one thing clear they can
bang on in public as much as they like
they just can't do it as the duke and
duchess of sussex as members of the
royal family strip them of the titles
they can yap away and by the way their
market value would go
but why shouldn't she know last word
hold on why shouldn't she name her
racially abused her because that's a
very strong accusation
should be
you're here gratitude of megan and i
know you're grateful about that oh i'm
here because megan that is actually true
i wouldn't be doing this show that
meghan markle's help thank you megan
thank you to my pen
[Music]
i'm tom newton dunn and this is talk tv
the most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did is interview went on one of the more
moves is going to launch a nuclear
strike on north korea or open up a shark
pit that i've been falling to
turn out he pressed it right at the end
of the interview and he walked a butler
with a tray and carrying a dark hood
here's the diet coke
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson liz trust
has vowed to deliver a bold agenda and
tackle the energy crisis after being
named as the winner of the tory
leadership race and britain's new prime
minister the foreign secretary beat
rishi sunak by just over 20 000 votes
trust will announce her new cabinet
tomorrow one person who won't be in her
government is pretty patel after she
resigned as home secretary this evening
in a letter to boris johnson she said
it's vital liz trust backs all aspects
of her policies to tackle illegal
immigration including the rwanda policy
and meghan markle has made her first
public appearance in the uk since the
queen's platinum jubilee accompanied by
harry the duchess of sussex delivered a
speech to young leaders in manchester at
the one young world summit and said that
it's very nice to be back in the uk
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign